In today's video,
we're going to see what happens
if we use extreme cold,
and a low pressure environment
to suck all of the moisture
out of some Orbeez.
[Music]
Guys, we have
some Orbeez left over,
and not just this
little bag of Orbeez,
but not too long ago,
we made our Diamond
play button sculpture
by pouring molten aluminum
that used to be our Diamond
play button into Orbeez,
and we still have most
of those Orbeez.
We have tens of
thousands of Orbeez,
I think here.
And while a few of them
are burned from being in contact
with our molten aluminum,
for the most part,
they're still intact.
They're still Orbeez,
and we wanted
to see what happens
if you freeze dry an orbee.
As we've explained
in a couple of other videos,
a freeze dryer works
by lowering the temperature,
and freezing whatever is
in the machine,
and then it pulls a vacuum,
and then it warms
up a little bit.
And as it warms up,
all of that frozen
liquid in there,
it gets turned into a vapor.
It sublimates like dry ice
turning into a vapor,
but we're doing it with water.
It does that
at low temperatures,
and very low pressures,
and so it just sort of sucks
all the water out of something
without it ever getting wet.
So we've got a lot of Orbeez,
like we have so many Orbeez,
and we want to see what happens
if we take all of the moisture
out of an Orbeez.
Just the entire
orbular of Orbeez.
Yes.
A few of the big ones
didn't really survive.
It's like a big piece of Jell-O.
But we're still going to try
and throw those in there too,
just see what happens.
We're going to throw
them in here.
We're going to add
some cameras, some lights,
and we're going to see
what happens to Orbeez
as you suck all
the moisture out of them.
My hope is that they
actually freeze together
during the freezing process,
and then maybe break
apart afterwards,
but I really want like a block
of freeze-dried orbeez.
So we've got a tray,
we've got some containers.
I think we can fill
these containers with Orbeez,
and then, we can also
just fill the tray
around the container
with even more Orbeez.
Let's fill things up.
[Music]
So again, we had a few of these
that like got
a little bit melted,
and you can kind of see
the residue of a plastic bucket.
When we poured molten aluminum
into a bucket of Orbeez,
we lost some of it
to the the plastic,
and so we,
I'm going to try
and filter these out,
just because I don't know
what that's going to do,
and I want this
to just be pure Orbeez.
[Music]
A ridiculous amount of Orbeez.
Let's add more.
Yeah.
[Music]
That's a lot of Orbeez.
That's a lot of Orbeez,
and two GoPros.
Saying the name of our cameras
actually turn them off.
They have voice activation
features, which is useful
until you forget,
and you say the name,
and they both turn off on you.
So the cameras,
the name of which
we will not say,
are in the freeze dryer.
Here we go.
Alright, so that's
the nine hours,
and while that's going,
make some more?
Yeah, why not?
We're about to ruin some.
[Music]
More?
Better to have too
many than too few.
[Music]
Our orbeez are finished.
The freeze dryer
has completed its cycle.
It took a long time.
We let this thing run
for about two days,
which is longer
than a lot of things need.
But Orbeez have a lot
of water in them.
It's cool watching
the time lapse of these,
just growing as well.
And Callie found a special one.
Okay guys, for some reason,
we had a bunch of Orbeez that
were Prince Rupert's drop shape,
but I, somebody may have
accidentally broken this one?
So really just
a tadpole shape,
but it's pretty cool.
Sometimes, they just grow tails.
I wonder if it's more likely
when you make larger batch,
not necessarily
because there's more,
but growing with
this many together.
We probably got like 10,000
in this jar, and so,
three out of ten thousand.
Let's open up our freeze dryer,
and see what we've got.
[Music]
Okay, that's awesome.
Those change.
I have a plate
of Fruity Pebbles now.
It's just like styrofoam.
Yeah, it sounds
like little styrofoam pebbles.
Okay, this is cool.
This is one of the larger ones.
The color has like seeped
to certain parts,
but the rest of it is
just almost like clear foam.
Some parts of them.
The water did not fully
get vacuumed out,
because somebody may have put
a lot of Orbeez in there.
Yeah.
We definitely got
most of it out,
but it looks like where it
was thicker blobs together.
All right.
So the stuff on the tray,
that we got really dry.
The stuff in the bowls...
Oh, interesting.
It's still-- that's like a--
Well, it's cold,
but it's not frozen.
And the big piles of it got
very well insulated,
so you can definitely see
that there's a difference.
All of this stuff
that's on the tray,
this was an orbee,
and now, it's just
this little plastic thing,
and I can just
smoosh it into dust.
Orbeez dust.
So fluffy and light.
The new kind of Orbeez art.
Just look at this one.
So a lot of these,
the colors like seeping out,
but that was perfectly Cobalt.
That's cool.
[Music]
Okay, new plan.
Hmm.
Huh?
No.
I'ts pretty solid.
Did anything break off of that?
Pieces fell off.
I don't think like broke
that all though.
Here you go.
You try.
Pickle jar worth
of solid block of ice.
You weakened that.
I smacked it
against the counter.
That's ice, right in the middle.
That's just solid ice.
>> But the outside is crunchy.
>> But like squished together Orbeez ice,
and like, I think ice
is actually filled in all
of the gaps between
where the Orbeez were.
It's gelatin ice.
Well, we've also got a jar
of warm water here.
So this is pretty nice and warm,
and warm water usually
activates Orbeez faster.
So I want to see what happens
if we start putting
these dehydrated bits
into the water.
So let's start with--
This is one still mostly frozen,
but not completely
freeze dried orbee.
[Music]
Wow.
That was only
a couple of minutes.
[inaudible] gelatinous.
I don't think it's
all the way through.
No, but it's--
It's still almost an orbee now.
The interesting thing is is
how many air bubbles
are in it now?
It's about the size
of a normal orbee, even if it
is a little misshapen though,
but it's just chock-full
of air bubbles.
There's some more like that one.
I think we should put in one
of these whole chunks.
I want this one.
It's just a cool shape.
Goodbye friend.
I mean, it's
probably gonna float.
[Music]
Pieces are just
falling off of it.
But the color is not
really staying anymore.
That's the biggest piece we got.
Yes, that was one
of the larger pieces
of a larger orbee,
about size of golf ball.
Now it's foam.
Let's see what that does.
I don't think this
is going to hold together.
So I'm just gonna control it.
Yep, and now it's...
Huh, interesting.
It's back to Orbeez texture.
But now, it's just
like a gelatinous--
It's like if you took a normal
orbee and crushed it up.
Yeah, pretty much.
Let's do a comparison even.
Pretty similar.
Yours is more crushed up, but--
But the texture is
very very similar.
So that's a regular orbee,
this was a freeze dried
and reconstituted orbee.
How does our brick doing?
Oh, gross.
But that underneath is cool.
Yeah, all the thawed portions
just scrape right off,
and leave the
frozen parts together.
Someone should make popsicles
that look like that.
Oh my gosh.
Shut up and take my money.
Shut Up And Take My Money.
So these are ones
that have dried out completely,
and I'm going to throw those
into some warm water.
See what happens to you.
[Music]
Are they dissolving?
Some of them had
so little cohesion.
Yeah, there's little,
little bits floating down
to the bottom.
[Music]
As the really open
ones absorb water,
you can see how they're sort
of turning into orbee shape.
But because there
are missing so much material,
they kind of shredded
as they freeze dried,
that we're now getting
like these frozen--
Instead of a sphere,
it's just like
a tissue-y substance.
All righrt, this is basically
just like pre-shredded.
It's hardly holding
itself together at all.
[Music]
This is awesome.
This was a solid chunk earlier.
I was like squishing
and flattening out pieces.
And now you can see
that some of them have actually
started to like bubble up,
and go back
to their normal shape,
but stayed in a popsicle form.
[Music]
Kinda have an interesting texture.
With normal Orbeez,
like you can feel the individual
shape of each marble.
But because of the way
these have broken up,
it's just more of like a slop.
But there's one other thing
I want to try is the Orbeez
now appear to all
be full of bubbles,
and most of the time,
if you throw Orbeez
into a vacuum chamber,
they don't really do anything.
I've tried it, nothing happens.
But because these are
now full of bubbles,
I want to try it with them.
So I'm just going to pour
off the extra water,
and then slap the vacuum
on to our jar here.
[Music]
Oh, yeah.
Those uh...
Those expands.
Turn that off.
Put the pressure back in.
See it decompress.
I think I actually sucked a lot
of water out of those as well.
I'm gonna see
if I can pour more water off.
I don't know.
Much more.
[Music]
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you to our latest video,
and that box at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit that bomb
in the middle to subscribe,
so you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see in the next one.
Talk to you then.